来吧,和大家要怎么做副业
包括怎么做主业
我们也是刚内部视频会完成,本事
所以我做一个剪辆的
该数吧
一个苏略吧,然后呢
帮助一些朋友,就是在
从现在到春底,对吧,把制定新年的计划可能对我帮助
那我还是想到了说呢,因为那种还是很有用的,但是想点说点
我要不是考虑说,你原本听一下外界的无所谓的
就是
现在说怎么做主业,我再说怎么做副业
首先,我们必须有一个能够让你保障基本生活的工作
这是必须我的
这是本定的,因为你只有稳定以后你后边才能做
所以你必须有一个稳定的工作
然后再稳定的工作纪录上
然后你去阻动去学习以下的计刀
什么计刀呢,首先第一个就是你要去
购店产品的计刀,就是做产品的计刀
为什么我能赚到钱
赵好今天我们在内部视频会里面有个老婆就跟说胡子哥我现在有留量
有个世界外的用户
但是我怎么并信
我说你要变现就必须有产品,能给别人提供价值的产品
就我完全有知识有什么东西有留量,但是你必须有东西给别人
提供所以你要学习怎么去做产品,就知道别人想要什么
发现别人学习,就这点练啊,然后怎么去解决怎么发的别人产品
这是第一个,这个计刀是叫练的
第二个计刀的话,就是你要练销售
你要练销售,就把东西卖续
这个计刀是要练习的
我现在其实高级点,因为我以前做过销是我在西安的时候
那是满大街,就推销那个滑上包子那个红钓
结果挺红人啊
拜不及,开个死了
但我现在会高级点,我现在做销售
我现在学习是更高级的销售
就是比如说在护联上拍一条段子里
这个是更高级的销售,我自己的例子是什么呢,我自己的例子就比如说
我们在线下的时候
有些不信阶都让太白达了
然后你在那儿足够谈味,为什么呢,因为这个地方有留量吗
你的东西好东西能被别人看到就能卖出去
现在互联网上有些地方留量标达
但这东西是好东西,让别人看到
你就能卖出去,对吧,我给大家去我意思
我们在人流量特别大的地方,那我可能是呈行
我真的是好的呈行
我变一点,让别人能温泽
对吧,好呈行
爱在别人看到的可能就卖了
就是这么落几,就好东西让别人能看到
所以呢,为什么很多人说我拍短视频没有留量,没有留量呢
首先,第一个问题是你用有好东西
对吧,让别人看到,那么
第二个问题就是说你要去去教授,但我个人更推荐的话,你要做点水
你要去拍短视频,把一些好的东西给别人分享出来,这是你要去的能力
那么,第三个能力的话,我个人是写做的,就是表达的能力,过通能力,对吧,演讲也好,写做也好
和人溝通的能力就很重要
然后还有,还有的话,就是组织写掉的
就是你在生活中
就是工作中,你要联系,首先你要保证一个问题,得收入来源,多少
不一定
如果你拿我个人来说,我的消费的欲望很低的,就会不需要那么多钱
过了生活
然后我重点的是
联系这个能力,注意啊,继续工作
就有些人联系,然后正的不是钱,正的是这个能力
这是第一个主义
然后我重点说些傅眼
其实我说有的时候,傅眼是很容易赚钱的
我这么说,可能会骂我
但你们好好体会,体会这一样
我说几点事情
第一点是行,一定要养成每天写点什么的习惯
这个写点什么是什么,包含什么,我给你解释一下
第一个,你每天做的什么事
我不管你做什么事,最好是有一公里标一个方向
我做的什么事
我失败了
我成功了,记下来,我遇到那些问题,我不管了,记下来
每天都去记,我干了什么事,我
记下,然后我总结了,我不管了记下来
然后每天去复盘的
记得吗,我之前进行,是我北京写点什么每天复盘
完了,那慢慢发了,你就会伤重一些长时
对吧,这个事就说,那个事有出现,你又三一反思
你三一总结,你把这长时,就是我觉得,哦,原来这个事,我总结的经验
我把他记下来,就穿了水,这种细节的,我的经验总结,我把他记下来
然后你在日常生活中,一带有人问你问题,拿,拿出一版的动作
今天是这些办法的什么问题,什么什么问题,我是怎么记得,把它做起来
被他们走,把它记下来
每天都玩得是
然后你就会发现你记上
每天都要做,大家在少一年把他记下来
一个月,两个月,三个月之后
你最好是在有个知诲,然后你问这个知诲
三个问题,拿三个问题,第一个问题
我每天经常做的事
根据我记得才俩,你认为我可以做什么
第二个问题
在我总结的这些长时里,我长总结的这种,今天就认
你认为我可以做什么事
第三件事,别人经常问我的,有哪些问题,这些问题我可以做什么事
你经历了几十天一百天之后
大家也会告诉你做什么事
我今天就举个小例子,就是我们的自己的老火箭
最开始是卖靠伤的
卖靠伤,我弟弟们老六啊,但很多老会就知道,刚才是卖靠伤的
就是跑到弟弟站,卖靠伤
如果我们真的记住,可以怎么记住啊,真的
我第一天,卖靠伤,我不知道怎么,我在卖的独自
我在卖的伤,然后我怎么靠的
对吧,我在那个弟弟站,我遇到什么问题,我卖不出去,我后来又怎么换了弟站
我怎么靠的,我怎么卖的,我遇到那些困难全部记得
你机上一个月两个月,后来早就赚钱了,就是从刚开始靠到最后赚钱了
这就是个小策子啊
对吧,小策是什么呢?就是
我是怎么从一无所有,到通过卖靠伤,第一个月正级映的
从刚开始怎么摆托,遇到那些问题,用了那些独自拆掉的一波而生,是不是可以总结出来的
那后来老六,坐弟次尼了,那我去在弟次尼,我是怎么坐的,我是怎么在弟次尼,正到小策的
对吧,我从刚开始,我怎么去的弟次尼,我怎么做的用过,我怎么这么一波来
是不是,兄弟们,这里面多意识什么呀?
好,我想一想啊,每天生活够接触了,然后你要断联的几个能力
然后呢,今年一九年你要去做一件事
如果你以前做过事,做一件大事了
如果以前没做过事,就做一件小事,大怕一件很小,很小的事
一年之内的,六个月三个月可以做的事情
就笨那个事去做
打个很小的要去做,做的公众每天,遇到问题上,几起来
卡定,几起来,千万,几起来
反思总结,几起来,别人们的问题,几起来
去干,每天干这个事
三个月以后,你问问,他可以做什么?
然后,你想他,王毅,成长,挂到晚上,总结一些知识,不断的河湾分享,这个钱你就做了